Russian State media says a major
Ukrainian offensive has been pushed back
it's reported to have happened along the
front line in southern Donetsk there's
been no comment from Kiev and the
reports have not been independently
verified Russia's defense Ministry has
released these pictures which allegedly
show the battle Moscow claims 250
Ukrainian soldiers were killed and
dozens of armored vehicles destroyed
in total the enemy deployed six
mechanized and two tank battalions the
enemy's goal was to break through our
defenses in the most vulnerable in its
opinion sector of the front the enemy
did not achieve its tasks it had no
success as a result of capable and
calculated actions of the group of
forces East the Ukrainian Army suffered
losses of more than 250 people 16 tanks
three armored personnel carriers and 21
armored vehicles
well it comes as two groups of Russian
paramilitaries fighting on the side of
Ukraine say they launched another raid
into Russia one of the groups the
Russian volunteer Corps has released a
video it says shows captured soldiers
including two lying wounded on hospital
beds it says it's ready to hand them
over to Ukrainian authorities
well the raid took place close to the
town of Navaya tabul zanka just four
kilometers across the border the
regional Governor says the town was
shelled from Ukraine before being
attacked
the second group involved in the raid
Liberty of Russia Legion has released
this Drone footage they say it shows
their Fighters carrying out the raid in
Belgard although it's unclear when it
was filmed
well papa felgangawa is a Russian
defense analyst he believes the plan is
to force Russia to move troops away from
the main fighting
I believe that the ukrainians hoped that
Russians are forced the Russia would
move reinforcements especially some
reinforcements as it was said that may
be the Wagner
storm troops will be moved there to
Belgrade that means they'll be moved out
from the south where most likely the
real fighting is going to happen in the
coming weeks or a couple of months so
that would be maybe the Ukrainian
objective
these uh small auxiliary groups cannot
really achieve a strategic
objective by their raids their only
strategic objectives is to pester the
Russians and make them reinforce forces
in Belgrade at the expense of other
places
meanwhile the Ukrainian military says
it's intercepted more than half of the
latest wave of Russian strikes against
its cities but one Missile hit the city
of danipra on Saturday killing a
two-year-old girl in a residential area
Charles Stratford has the latest from
Keith
niak sits among the rubble
civilian homes destroyed by what the
Ukrainian governor of the region says
was a Russian cruise missile
the two-year-old girl was found dead
buried in the destruction
more than 20 other people including five
children were also injured in Saturday
night's attack in the nebro OK
I was running across the traffic I was
running home my child was alone at home
we tried to pull my child under the cage
over the window we took the cage off and
took my kid out he's been treated now
Ukrainian authorities say they
intercepted the majority of the cruise
missiles and drones launched by Russian
forces in this attack but some got
through destroying civilian lives
here's my son's apartment which was
destroyed there is a crater on the first
floor a young family lived on the second
floor a two-year-old child died the
mother is undergoing care now
Russia says it avoids targeting civilian
areas but this is just one of hundreds
of attacks hitting places where people
live
Ukraine's prosecutor general office says
at least
485 children have been killed and
another 1 500 injured in Ukraine since
Russia's Invasion last year
people who lost their property four
Apartments were completely destroyed we
also see that houses that cannot be
restored must be completely demolished
people lost their lives in these houses
in these apartments
there's been an escalation in Russian
cruise missile and so-called Kamikaze
drone attacks in recent weeks and they
come ahead of a long-expected Ukrainian
counter-offensive in operation that the
Ukrainian leader Vladimir zielinski says
his military is now ready to start
as the fighting intensifies in the
coming weeks it's expected that more
civilians including children will die